c'est un peu le combat de david contre
goliath quatre communes et huit
associations du plateau de saclay opposé
ensemble à un projet de plusieurs
milliards d'euros porté par l'état et
les principaux élus du territoire
un combat qu'il mène principalement
depuis la déclaration d'utilité publique
de la ligne 18
il y a un an lorsque l'on regarde donc
un public qui a été menée dans le détail
on s'aperçoit très bien que il ya toute
une partie de l' enquête publique qui a
été de l'avis des gens qui ont été
complétés auditionné qui a été écartée
ou interprétés c'est là où on s'aperçoit
que la société du grand paris a essayé
de masquer
la vider les gens pour faire passer son
projet trop cher trop dangereuses pour
l'environnement est inefficace pour
répondre aux besoins du plateau de
saclay élus et associations locaux ont
déposé en tout deux recours devant le
conseil d'état
leurs espoirs se faire entendre sur
leurs propositions
tous les alternatives qui aurait pu être
notamment des transports innovants sous
forme de petits véhicules ou des
téléphériques etc tous ces projets là
ils ont été étouffés ils ont été tués
dans l'oeuf
on a tous privilégié sur la ligne 18
personnes ne connaît véritablement le
dossier technique
or nous ce dossier technique nous
l'avons largement étudiés et nous savons
qu'il ya des possibilités autres qui
coûterait beaucoup moins cher et qui
serait beaucoup plus facile à mettre en
oeuvre des idées et des projets que les
élus du plateau de saclay pourront
présenter lors d'un rendez vous à
matignon le 22 mars prochain
c'est en mars aussi que le gouvernement
doit enfin annoncé le nouveau calendrier
de grand paris express